Abu Salim Atta Ali is 17 he's being held
in the rebel compound outside to Homer
who was part of khamis gaddafi
protection team and he's absolutely
terrified
but this boy who was not in any trouble
is the only person to have seen Colonel
Gaddafi since the fall of Tripoli sandy
I'm good no see don't good energy and he
said that he was visiting us at the same
time when we run away from a nice combo
did he see Colonel Gaddafi in the
compound should they get better shooter
yes and what what where did he go does
he know what happened to him shouldn't
say lan-evo Marquand know how or to
think Julie said father and he said I
mean he go out with Donna Donna me a big
number of tracks towards to serve her on
Friday Gadhafi arrived at the Hamish
compound to meet his son it's now
overrun by the rebels of course but at
the time the Gaddafi forces were
preparing to flee they were involved in
this gun battle which we were caught up
in just as a meeting took place
hello honey so I didn't just talk with
honey's not always cameras dedicated
that ashes Diego vesser
and just I mean 10 to 15 minutes talking
with homies and get the car and go out
as the meeting was underway Colonel
Gaddafi's daughter Asia also arrived and
according to Abu Salim they changed cars
and headed out together they were aiming
south for his stronghold in suburban I
mean obviously from a distance did he
have anyone else with him anyone he
recognized fish camp had the lion had
thought I say
ich bin - the huntin Schiffman his
daughter Asha was with him I could I'd
like to see Shabaab anthem Co not too
thick lucre ecology and he said one of
the I mean high ranking soldiers come to
us and we asked him what is the head of
yous going to he said to supper and we
asked him so if we can def is going to
somehow and what are we doing here we
have to leave also he said no all of us
we are going to believe Abu Salim
Mohammed headed down this road aiming
for the town of Bani Walid at Gaddafi
stronghold on the way they were attacked
by NATO and rebel forces cars and trucks
were destroyed including this one an
armored Toyota Landcruiser abot slim
says Hammes had swapped cars and got
into the Toyota I showed him a picture
of the car to the tree but this is the
what is left of the car is that the
glove because the language ID and the
bag Madame Mata love
yes pretty sure no and does he think how
much was in that car
I miss I've got to see I had you shorten
no good yes
he's sure advil Salam will continue to
be questioned here but the military say
that he's not really done anything wrong
he's only 17 and that he'll almost
certainly been released very soon but
his information is significant he's the
only person to confirm that Colonel
Gaddafi was alive and in Tripoli right
up to the weekend of course he is the
last person to see Hamish Gaddafi before
his vehicle was attacked the boy had
been with Hamish for just one month he
volunteered to help because he was told
that foreigners had invaded the country
the biggest surprise he said after being
captured is that everyone was Libyan he
had no idea Stuart auntie Sky News
tellin